>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Regan Smith: Okay,
I think we're waiting
for one participant who's a couple
minutes away, but we'll go ahead
and start and he can
join when he gets here.
Welcome to the roundtable discussion
for the Copyrights Office study
on Section 1201 of the DMCA.
Thank you for being here.
My name is Regan Smith,
I'm Associate General Counsel
of the Copyright Office.
As you know, the Office is
conducting this study in accordance
with a request from the House
Judiciary Committee's ranking member
in response to the Register
of Copyrights' Testimony
in a 2015 Copyright Review
Hearing regarding the impact
and the efficacy of Section 1201 and
the triennial rulemaking process.
If you're hear, you're probably
familiar with 1201, but just,
I wanted to provide a
little bit of background
into the statute and
how it was enacted.
1201 is part of the
DMCA enacted in 1998.
And in enacting it,
Congress recognized
that technological protection
measures could be deployed not only
to prevent piracy and other
economically harmful unauthorized
uses of copyrighted material,
but also to support new ways
of dissemination of copyrighted
material to users digitally.
So Section 1201 protects
circumvention
of technological measures employed
on or behalf of copyright owners
to control access to their
works known as access controls,
as well as anti-trafficking
provisions preventing trade
in either services or tools of
access controls or copy controls
that protect rights to
copyright owners under Title 17.
Section 1201 also includes a
triennial rulemaking process
by which the Librarian of Congress,
following a public proceeding
conducted by the Copyright Office,
in consultation with NTIA,
can grant limited exceptions
to Section 1201(a)(1)'s bar on the
circumvention of access controls.
The rulemaking is intended
as a failsafe mechanism
through which the Copyright
Office can monitor developments
in the marketplace and recommend
limited exemptions to protect --
to prevent the restriction of
fair and non-infringing uses.
The rulemaking has expanded
with each successive cycle.
In the first rulemaking, the Office
received nearly 400 comments,
and that resulted in the
granting of two exemptions.
In the sixth rulemaking, which
was concluded last October,
we received nearly 40,000 comments.
We considered 27 categories and
granted 22 of the exemptions.
Some of the categories in the last
rulemaking concerned the ability
to access and make
non-infringing uses of works
such as motion pictures,
ebooks, and videogames.
But others concerned access
to copyrighted computer code
in consumer devices ranging
from cell phones to smart TVs,
automobiles, tractors, 3D
printers and pacemakers.
The Registrar said
in her recommendation
that while it's clear 1201
has played an important role
in developing secure platforms
for digital distribution
of copyrighted works, it
is also impacting a range
of consumer activities
that have little to do
with the consumption
of creative content.
It also has become obvious that
the regulatory process has become
burdensome for participants in these
rulemakings, especially when seeking
to renew exemptions and that
the permanent exemptions,
such as for security research,
encryption research, or privacy,
may have not adequately
foreseen some
of the developments since the DMCA.
So this is the genesis
for our study.
We thank you for submitting
your written comments
which we're looking
at, and we're hoping
that these roundtables will
facilitate a deeper discussion.
Kevin is going to explain
the logistics
and then kick off panel one.
>> Kevin Amer: Good morning.
My name is Kevin Amer.
I'm Senior Counsel in
the Office of Policy
and International Affairs
here at the Copyright Office.
Before we begin, I'd just like to
go over a few logistical items.
First, the -- the roundtable
sessions will be moderated
by us here at the table.
We will pose questions or
-- or topics for discussion.
And we ask that to indicate that
you would like to be recognized,
you please turn your
name card vertically.
This will be familiar to some
of you who've been to WIPO,
and we'll then call on you.
Just given the number of
panelists and the number of topics
that we are hoping to cover,
we ask that you please try
to limit your comments to
about two to three minutes.
We apologize profusely
in advance, if --
if you do go over substantially,
we will unfortunately
have to cut you off.
We -- you know, we appreciate
your understanding as we try
to accommodate a lot of
different viewpoints and hear
from a broad range of speakers.
We also ask, obviously,
that you focus your comments
on the particular topics that we
provided in our notice of inquiry
or to particular questions
that -- that we raise.
Also, we've been asked if --
if at the end of your comment,
if you could please
turn off your microphone
because that avoids interference
on the sound recording.
Second, as you can see, today's
event is being video recorded
by the Library of Congress.
Panelists, we've provided you
with a video release form.
If you haven't yet signed
it, please do so and --
and return it to one of
us here at the table.
In addition, as you can see, we --
we do have a court reporter
transcribing the proceedings.
And finally, just before we
begin, we'd just like to note
that we may seek additional written
comments in response to some issues
that may come up during
the roundtables.
If we do, we obviously will
provide a formal notice of inquiry.
So at this time, I'd like to
ask everyone in the audience
to please turn off or mute
any cell phones or devices
that could interfere
with the recording.
Does anyone have any questions about
logistics before we get started?
Okay. Great.
Before we begin, I'd just
like to ask my other
Copyright Office colleagues
to introduce themselves quickly.
>> Abi Mosheim: I'm Abi Mosheim.
>> Jason Sloann: I'm Jason
Sloan, attorney-advisor
in the General Counsel's Office.
>> Kevin Amer: And then, if we
could just go around the table,
if you all could just
please introduce yourself
and your affiliation,
we'll start with Mr. Adler.
[ Inaudible Microphone Off ]
Oh, if you would, turn on
your microphone, if you would.
>> Allan Adler: Sure.
I think it was on, right.
Oh, okay. My name is Allan Adler.
I'm general counsel and Vice
President for Government Affairs
for the Association of
American Publishers,
a national trade association
for book
and journal publishing industry.
>> Jonathan Band: I'm Jonathan
Band, I'm here on behalf
of the Library Copyright Alliance.
>> Troy Dow: I'm Troy Dow
with the Walt Disney Company.
>> Robyn Greene: Robyn
Greene, Policy Counsel
with New America's Open
Technology Institute.
>> Aaron Lowe: Aaron Lowe with
the Auto Care Association.
We represent manufacturers,
distributors, retailers
and installers of auto
parts independent
and other vehicle manufacturers.
>> Raza Panjawani: My
name is Raza Panjwani.
I'm a Policy Counsel
at Public Knowledge.
>> Stan Pierre-Louis:
I'm Stan Pierre-Louis.
I'm the General Counsel of the
Entertainment Software Association
and we represent the
U.S. videogame industry.
>> George Slover: George
Slover, Senior Policy Counsel
for Consumers Union, the policy
and advocacy division
of Consumer Reports.
>> Brian Weissenberg:
I'm Brian Weissenberg.
I'm a law student at Stanford Law
School's IP Innovation Clinic,
representing the Institute of
Scrap Recycling Industries.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Jonathan Zuck
from ACT, The App Association.
>> Kevin Amer: Great.
Well, welcome everyone.
So the first session is entitled
"Relationship of Section 1201
to Copyright Infringement,
Consumer Issues and Competition,"
and this session will explore
the role and effectiveness
of Section 1201 in
protecting copyrighted content
and will consider how the statute
should accommodate interests
that are outside of
core copyright concerns.
So I think we wanted to start just
by getting your view on asking sort
of a big picture question
and getting your views on --
on the overall role and
effectiveness of Section 1201.
We had a lot of comments noting the
-- the different distribution models
that TPMs have facilitated.
And I think some other
comments, you know,
we had several examples of those.
We had some other comments
that I think questioned sort
of the relationship between the
legal protection of TPMs and --
and the effectiveness of those TPMs.
So I think we'd be interested,
just sort of in your general views,
about the extent to which the
legal protections provided by --
for TPMs, provided under Section
1201 contribute to the effectiveness
of technological protection measures
in protecting copyrighted content.
[ Silence ]
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So I think,
as lawyers, we like to feel
that we have an impact on the world.
But I have a feeling that in this
area, you know, the -- the --
the technological protection
measures,
to the extent that they've been
effective in protecting the rights
of copyright owners, it's
because the technological
protection measures have been
technologically effective.
We saw early on ineffective
measures such as CSS
that were very easy to hack.
And, you know, the -- the -- the
-- the technology to hack it,
DeCSS, was widely available.
There was some hacking
of it, some not.
But -- but we now are,
you know, in --
in generations way beyond that
in terms of the effectiveness
of technological protection
measures, especially with respect
to all -- all kinds of content
that's in the cloud and you have to,
you know, behind very
secure paywalls.
And I -- I think that the --
the law has nothing to do with
the effectiveness of those --
of those systems, certainly to
the extent that one's worried
about the general public.
I mean, I'm sure some people hack
into those systems
from time to time.
But what makes those work --
and they work very well --
is the technology, not the
-- not the legal protection.
And to the extent that
one's worried about hacking
and this unlawful hacking into these
systems, you have the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act and you have --
every state has its own anti-hacking
statute, so there's -- there's --
there's this whole other array
of laws that come into effect.
So I think, certainly as they are
in the current form, I think the --
the 1201 protections really have
very little to do with the success
of -- of these technological
protection measures.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: I think it was
recognized very early on, in fact,
because this legislation,
as we know, was the result
of an international
treaty that determined
that legal protections were
important for technological measures
that were used to control
access to copyrighted works.
And that was not an accident
because I think the --
the commonsensical proposition
there is that having the ability
to use locks, if you will,
or technological measures
to control access, means nothing
if there are no legal restrictions
against people violating those locks
or others in creating the devices
or offering services
to violate those locks.
So when -- when this legislation
was enacted, it wasn't surprising
that the House Judiciary Committee
compared the use of this to, quote,
electronic equivalent of breaking
into a locked room in order
to obtain a copy of a book.
The idea here was all about access.
It is to facilitate consumer
access to works online
because that would be
convenient, because it was viewed
that that would cut expenses,
it would cut against the --
the difficulties people
have in finding these works.
But the notion of bringing access
online meant that access had
to be secure in the
face of all the ways
in which online digital
networks are susceptible
to having people engaging
in unauthorized activities.
So we think that the legal
protections were a necessary part
of the notion that copyright owners
could use technological protection
measures in order to make
their works conveniently
and ubiquitously available online
and that's been a wild success.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thank you,
and thanks for having
me here this morning.
I -- it -- I may date
myself a little bit,
but I remember very clearly going to
Egghead Software and buying a copy
of a piece of software called
Copy II PC, and that's how,
in my younger unruly days, I copied
software that I wanted to use
because it took -- it took
creating copyrighted material
to respect it in my particular case.
I think the real purpose
of the legal allowances
and the legal prohibitions that
1201 offers is taking the technology
out of the mainstream.
It's not an all-or-nothing
proposition.
There's still going to be hackers.
There's still going to be people
that gain access to technology.
But the widespread acceptability of
that technology, that I just walk
into a Best Buy, for example, and
buy software to break encryption,
is I think what really
is changed by the --
the legal provisions
that are put in place.
So that's -- that's the connection.
I think it has to do with -- with
numbers more than it does a sort
of binary connection that -- between
the two, if that makes sense.
>> Kevin Amer: I think
Mr. Panjwani was next.
[ Silence ]
>> Raza Panjawani: Thank you.
When the WIPO Copyright
Treaty was adopted
and the United States was
considering enacting the Digital
Millennium Copyright Act,
the consideration I believe
at the time -- I wasn't
there personally --
was that there was a necessity
to provide protections
for rights holders in
order to encourage them
to provide digital goods and
to distribute them online.
One of the things we have seen
is that DRM is not necessary
for a number of business models.
And business owners are entitled to
choose how they wish to distribute,
but we've seen the adoption of
iTunes taking a DRM-free stance,
we have seen CD Projekts GOG.com
game distribution platform sells
both classic and newer
releases without DRM,
the Tor Book in print also
releases ebooks without DRM.
In the last 7 to 10 years, we've
seen a move away from the assumption
that DRM is absolutely necessary
to have a digital economy.
Considering that Section
1201 takes that assumption
and then burdens the public's rights
to engage in non- infringing uses
in order to provide
these protections,
I think it's worth reengaging
in a cost-benefit analysis
of to what extent do we still need
these very high barriers in order
to encourage digital distribution.
Beyond that, I think it's
worth talking about the fact
that how effective 1201 has actually
been in curtailing digital piracy,
which is something that
Congress explicitly called
out in its legislative history as
a reason for enacting Section 1201.
In our comments, we pointed
to a number of statements
by various copyright industries
decrying the level of piracy
that is occurring online
and digitally.
And I -- while I know some folks
have responded by saying that, well,
we need to look at the
digital markets we've created,
the content that has been allegedly
made available by circumventing DRM
and that is available in these
marketplaces is the same,
it's not separate.
And I think separating these two
sort of conflates correlation
and causation, that because of
DRM, we now have digital markets.
I don't think that's
necessarily true.
>> Kevin Amer: How do
we sort of get at that?
I mean, in -- in your experience as
-- I'll open this up to everyone --
as practitioners, is
-- is it your sense
that 1201 actions are --
are relatively common?
Is this -- I mean, I think we had
some disagreement in the comments
as to sort of how commonplace
1201 actions are.
I'd be interested in -- in
your thoughts on that or to --
to pick up on the previous question.
I think Mr. Pierre-Louis was next.
>> Stan Pierre-Louis: Thank you.
In about a month, ESA will
be hosting the E3 Tradeshow
which is our -- the world's
premier videogame tradeshow
where you've got consoles
with new capabilities,
new games and software.
All that's made possible because of
the twin goals achieved by the DMCA.
When it was passed in 1998, the --
the thought was, we want
to expand consumer access
to broadband and to
new technologies.
And one of the ways
we encourage that is
by getting copyrighted content
online and on other devices.
And part of those twin
goals involved 1201.
We've seen that growth which
makes not only our tradeshow
but our industry a growing
one, $23.5 billion now, the --
the largest of the media
companies -industries.
And that happens because
we know that our investment
in our technologies
and in our software
and in our copyrighted
content will get protected.
When we're talking about
various companies deciding
to issue certain content
DRM-free, that's a choice.
1201 doesn't require --
is not a required statute.
It's -- it's one that says, if
you implement this technology,
it will have the force of law
if someone tries to bypass it.
But you don't have to use it.
And we've seen many models,
even within our own industry,
with people putting
out games that are free
to play and freemium models.
And so, we've seen
the various models win
out because different games
and different companies
have different goals.
It doesn't mean one is mandated and
certainly there's no tech mandate
in it, but I think, if
companies decide to go DRM-free,
that's certainly not only allowable
but that's another way
to access consumers.
>> Regan Smith: Picking up on
Kevin's question, in your industry,
are you aware of instances of using
1201 as an enforcement either,
you know, in courts
or prior to litigation
to protect the integrity of the DRM?
>> Stan Pierre-Louis: The --
the good news about our industry
is we've had a lot of success,
particularly with the newer console
models, in preventing that access.
And so we've not had to rely
on it in terms of legal claims.
But we know that having it
as a backstop protects us.
We are a U.S.-only
trade association,
but we know that internationally
we've had that success as well.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think Mr. Dow was next.
>> Troy Dow: Thank you.
So Mr. Band talked about
that there appeared not
to be any direct correlation
between the legal protections
and the advancement of the goal
of making the material
available digitally online
and that the real value was
in the technology itself.
And I think that there is real
value in the technology itself.
And if you go back and you
look at the NII Whitepaper
that made the recommendations that
led to the adoption of the DMCA,
it was very explicit in saying
that in this new environment,
the copyright owners would look to
technology to protect their rights
and that would be a very
valuable tool in terms of helping
to promote the growth
of digital commerce
but that technology alone would
be insufficient to meet that goal,
and that legal protections
alone would also be insufficient
to meet that goal.
And it was the combination of the
two that were going to be required
to meet the objective of
encouraging people to sort of jump
with both feet into a new digital
environment in which content,
in a very high quality,
was put at risk.
And I think the experience has
been that that's what has resulted
from the DMCA, that people have
relied on the legal protections,
combined with the technological
protections,
to get into these businesses with
both feet, perhaps more quickly
than otherwise would
have been the case.
I -- I know that the
availability of the --
the WIPO Treaties and
their discussions,
the DMCA were directly
relevant to the adoption
of CSS as a protection for DVD.
It was what led to the
introduction of the DVD,
which became the fastest
growing consumer platform --
consumer electronics platform
up to that time in history.
Jonathan is right that that --
that that technology was hacked
and that there were tools
available to defeat it,
but that's also what
spawned much of the --
the precedent that we have
right now in the DMCA is
in enforcement litigation under
the DMCA dealing with those things.
And it's not -- and the
objective was never to say
that these technologies
would be hack-proof
or that there would never
be anyone who would be able
to access the tools to do it,
or that would be able to figure
out a way to do it, but that
you would keep these things
out of the mainstream.
And that's exactly what that
litigation had the effect of doing.
And you know, Mr. Zuck talks
about going into the Best Buy
and being able to buy
hacking software.
Well, when we were in
litigation with 321 Studios
over CSS hacking technology,
that was exactly the issue,
was that you could walk
into Fry's and Best Buy
and buy consumer-friendly hacking
technology to -- to rip DVDs.
And the litigation that was involved
there didn't remove the ability
to hack DVDs, but it did
take that activity and put it
at the fringes while leaving
a channel in the mainstream
that helped to promote the --
the availability of these
new business models.
Now, in the last 15 years
that I've been in --
involved in this from a business
side, I've been at the intersection
of the law and sort of the business
considerations, and I can tell you
that the availability of these legal
tools has been directly relevant
to the decisions to
get into these markets,
whether it was the development of
AACS as a next-generation standard
for the protection of high
definition digital content,
whether it's the willingness
to get into the market for 4K,
whether it's the willingness to
get into the market for the --
over-the-top television and
authenticated television
to allow people to do streaming,
the DMCA has been a factor
in the willingness to engage
in all of those things.
And so, I think it's --
from our perspective,
has been both necessary
and successful.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Slover?
>> George Slover: So in
-- in our experience here,
it's not been the --
the intended uses
of the technological protection
measures in Section 1201,
it's the -- the overbroad uses which
I think were probably not intended
or certainly not fully
envisioned in 1998.
So it's, you know, we -- we
heard the metaphor a minute ago
from the House Judiciary
Committee of breaking into a house
in order to steal a book.
I think of another metaphor,
which is my wife has baked a cake
which she intends to
take to church on Sunday,
and my teenaged son is hungry.
And so she can either say,
hey, don't touch that cake,
or she can say, you know what, I'm
so afraid you might touch that cake,
I don't even want you
setting foot in the kitchen,
and I'm going to lock
that kitchen door.
You can't get into the refrigerator,
you can't get into the cupboard,
you're just going to have to
go hungry because I'm worried
about that cake on the counter.
I think there -- I'm hoping
there's a way to sort of reconfigure
and reconstitute what
we're doing with 1201
so that we're really
focused on the --
the protection against infringement,
and we're not capturing the
interoperability and -- and --
and, in my view, less
closely-related side benefits of --
to industry of -- of -- of
denying access to the software.
>> Regan Smith: Building --
connecting those two thoughts,
Mr. Dow just said that 1201 has
been both necessary and successful
in the motion picture
type of industries,
and you've mentioned
going sort of overbroad.
Is -- has 1201 played a role
in protecting or any sort
of useful role in the markets
for 3D printers or software
that anyone's aware of, or cars?
[ Silence ]
>> Aaron Lowe: So yeah, we take
it to sort of a different place.
I mean, we're -- what -- what
Mr. Slover said is very clear
from our -- from our industry.
We're -- the automotive
aftermarket is
about a $350 billion
industry in this country.
And that industry provides
choices to consumers in auto parts
and where they get
those cars serviced.
And we're seeing the use of software
in virtually every
component on a car nowadays.
And those components --
some of them, we're not
clear whether they're there
for functional purposes or simply
to make it difficult for people
to produce parts to
work on their vehicles.
And we're seeing the use of --
of the 1201 as a way to keep
our industry out of being able
to reverse engineer and --
and produce parts and even
service those vehicles.
So we see a pretty broad impact
on our industry going forward
and even currently, we're seeing
more and more parts, which is --
with -- with chips on them to --
that are making it difficult for
our industry to -- to operate in --
in -- in the aftermarket.
>> Kevin Amer: So I think we're
going to go with Mr. Weissenberg,
then Mr. Zuck, Mr. Band,
and then Ms. Greene,
and then I think we're going
to go on to another question.
So Mr. Weissenberg?
>> Brian Weissenberg: I just wanted
to quickly piggyback
off Mr. Slover here
and answer your question, Kevin.
An example of someone using the
DMCA or 1201 specifically to --
to go after someone or file a claim.
Last year, when ISRI was here
asking for a 1201 exemption
for phone unlocking, TracFones
response was, you know,
we rely on 1201 to protect our
business model, and we emphasize
that that's not a copyright
interest and we're grateful, again,
for the Copyright Office
for recognizing that fact.
And that kind of bleeds
into another topic.
I don't want to get there just yet,
but just in case you need
another example, that's one.
>> Kevin Amer: Okay.
Yeah. And -- and definitely we're
going to try to explore some
of these competition issues
later on in this panel.
Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thank you.
Yeah. I don't -- I don't want to be
accused of two bites of the apple
or smuggling a file in a cake or
anything like that, but the --
some of the questions have
evolved as we've gone along here,
and I wanted to address
a couple of comments.
One is the notion that
there's other business models
that don't involve DRM, and
that's certainly the case.
And I think it's important and
worth mentioning that the people
that make use of DRM don't like it.
It's -- it's not enjoyable to --
to go through the process of trying
to use technical protection
measures on your products.
It increases consumer support
costs and everything else.
It's simply been a necessary
tool in preventing piracy.
And I can say that it's certainly
been a very successful tool
in the context of software as well.
And in the app market that
I represent, the distinction
between software and content
is becoming continually blurred
as well.
So TPMs are used, not only for
the software itself but also
for the content that's
embedded in --
in software where some
of the piracy occurs.
If I've got an app that's teaching
you yoga positions or something
like that, sometimes the piracy
involves pulling the content
out of the app and
repurposing it in another app.
So TPMs have proven useful
in the software market.
And then, the final
point is this notion
about it expanding beyond
its original intention.
And I -- I feel like that
comes up over and over again.
And in this context, I always remind
everyone that I'm not a lawyer.
But it's my understanding that where
those things have been adjudicated,
they've come out in favor of a
more restrictive interpretation
of -- of the DMCA.
So I mean, I -- the -- you know,
whether it's garage door openers
or printer cartridges
and things like that,
I think there's some fairly strong
precedents in place to suggest
that it should be focused on
-- on copyright infringement.
And the -- and the jail-breaking
legislation is another example,
I think, of where the
system worked to --
to, you know, modify the environment
in which people are getting overly
experimental in the use of 1201.
But none of that, I
think, undermines the value
that it's played in what has
been a very successful market,
and I think we should be very
cautious about upending that.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So going --
going back to your question about,
you know, the number of cases,
I think you're right, there --
there have been relatively few
1201 cases, certainly relative
to the number of, let's
say, of 512 cases.
And it's always important when we're
talking about 1201 to also keep
in mind that it's part of this
bigger construct of the DMCA.
But one of the reasons why there's
been relatively few 1201 cases,
it seems to me, is that it's
-- it's really broadly drafted.
It talks about, not only
the act of circumvention,
but it talks about trafficking,
then there's also 1201(b).
The early cases, you know, went very
strongly in favor of rights holders,
and so, there was very -- there
just hasn't been a need for the --
the litigation because it's
-- it's been -- it's --
it's been so broadly interpreted.
So -- so then, the action
really has shifted very much
to the rulemaking because,
you know, there --
you have all these people
who are adversely affected,
and if you're adversely
affected by the DMCA,
I mean you have two choices, you
could sort of go ahead and engage
in the activity and hope that,
in the event of litigation,
that you'll end up with, you know,
you'll end up in the right court,
right, that you'll end up in the
-- in the Federal Circuit, I guess,
or the Sixth Circuit, as
opposed to the Ninth Circuit.
But, you know, yeah, good luck
in making sure that that happens.
If you're on the defendant side,
you don't really get to choose
where the action is filed.
And you know, that's one choice.
Or the choice is to -- to
-- to go to the rulemaking.
And so, so much of the
activity and the energy is
on the rulemaking side because, you
now, at least there is a rulemaking.
So we're glad for that.
But that's why, you know,
because the DMCA is so broad
and has been interpreted so
broadly by some circuits, you know,
that's pushed all the activity and
the focus onto the rulemaking side
and that's why so much -- so many
of us are so intent on trying
to get the -- the rulemaking
to work better than it is.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Ms. Greene?
>> Robyn Greene: Thank you.
I was actually just going to
say some of what was just stated
with regard to the reason why
there is not a tremendous amount
of litigation and the fact that
there have been favorable decisions
in -- in previous court cases.
What I do want to note about that
though is that it is impossible
to calculate the chilling effect
that those previous court cases,
even though they were ruled on
favorably, has had on the market.
Entrepreneurs who are just trying
to enter a marketplace may not want
to take the risk that all
of the efforts that they go
to to develop a new product,
to innovate, and to launch it
in the marketplace may be for
naught as a result of litigation,
even if they might
eventually win that litigation.
And so, that -- that is
a -- a great concern.
And then, to the extent that it
has been, you know, pushed --
the litigation has been pushed
to the rulemaking process.
I do still think there is
a chill in the marketplace
and a chill specifically
in activities
that are very clearly not
related to copyright infringement,
such as security research, and the
burdens of that rulemaking process,
which I know we'll
be discussing later,
I think do oftentimes go outside of
the question of the effectiveness
of TPMs in -- in helping
the marketplace,
and in fact sometimes favor the
chill of that type of competition.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
So turning from the
effectiveness and the role of the --
the current law, I think we wanted
to explore a little bit some
of the proposed changes to 1201,
and really one of the central points
of dispute, or disagreement
that we saw in the comments,
is this idea that there is or
should be a nexus within 1201
with copyright infringement.
We had a, you know, large number of
comments supporting the -- the --
the model obviously
and the Unlocking Technology
Act that's been proposed
that would limit circumvention
violations to those undertaken
for the purpose of infringement.
In response, we had several
comments saying that the --
that accessing a copyrighted
work for purposes
of consumption alone may not
implicate an exclusive right,
and indeed, that type of activity
is -- is really the, you know,
one of the -- the foundational
reasons why Section 1201
was enacted.
So I'd like to sort of explore
that debate a little bit.
What are your views as to
proposals to incorporate a nexus
to infringement within 1201?
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: Oh, there
is a nexus to infringement
in 1201, but it's not in 1201 --
>> Kevin Amer: Oh,
microphone, please.
>> Allan Adler: There is
a nexus to infringement
in 1201, but it's not in 1201(a).
1201(a) is about access
controls, and "access" is not part
of the exclusive rights of
a copyright owner under 106.
But obviously, access to the work
is the threshold issue with respect
to whether or not uses of the work
that implicate the exclusive
rights are going to occur.
If you look at -- at the way
Congress structured 1201,
1201(a) was designed to deal with
the question of access independent
of the issue of infringement
because access to the work, again,
was the question about whether or
not consumers were going to be able
to exploit the marketplace and
whether there would be a marketplace
of these works online to exploit.
When you look at -- at 1201(b),
1201(b) doesn't address the question
of circumvention of a
technological protection measure
that protects rights of a
copyright owner under section 106
and Title 17, specifically
because it recognizes
that those rights are themselves
subject to exceptions like fair use.
But that's why those two questions
have to be looked at differently.
The issue of access is
not about infringement.
And to the extent that Congress
did seek to allow copyright owners
to utilize technological protection
measures to deal with the issue
of infringement, that was done in
1201(b) where the balance was struck
in recognizing limitations
and exceptions like fair use,
while still suggesting that even
though there already are remedies
in the law to deal
with infringement,
technological measures can still
help a copyright owner be able
to deal with that by
at least making sure
that to the extent they do use
technological protection measures
to protect exclusive rights,
that those are not subject
to a marketplace that's rife
with availability of the means
to circumvent those measures.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So I -- I think
the premise of 1201(a) was --
Allan's right, it's about access.
But it's about access -- I
think what everyone had in mind
and everyone thought they
were talking about was access
to something you hadn't
paid for, right?
I mean, it was -- the idea was,
you know, it was -- it was --
it was like getting, you know, and
the people were talking about sort
of getting access to cable
television that, you know, to --
get access -- getting access
to the premium channel
that you hadn't paid for.
That's what it was -- but that's
what I think everyone really had
in their mind.
And certainly not the situation
that Mr. Lowe is dealing
with in the automotive context
about a person not being able
to access his own software in
his own car for the purpose
of making sure that he doesn't pay
marked up prices for repair parts,
and that -- and that that was
not at all what was contemplated.
Now, one can debate
what the words say
and how they probably should be
-- properly should be interpreted,
but I think it is fair to say
that there's no policy reason
within the confines of the
Copyright Act or within the confines
of Section -- of Title 17, for
there to be any restrictions
on a person's ability to
access their own property,
their own copies.
It's one thing to say
I shouldn't be able
to access something I haven't
paid for, but if I've paid for it
and it's in my possession,
you know, why --
why should there be
a legal framework
that protects my ability
to access that?
And so, that's why, you
know, we think the -- the --
the Technology Unlocking Act makes
sense and that's why, you know --
and -- and -- and whether it's --
it's through a statutory change
or through a much more
liberal application of the --
of the rulemaking in the
case of, at least software
where we see this problem
most pervasively, you know,
we would be able to sort of
simplify your work significantly
and not have the DMCA basically
regulating the entire U.S. economy.
>> Regan Smith: So earlier we
heard about the various types
of digital distribution, and is
your theory that 1201 should --
should be limited to --
consumers should be able
to access what they have paid for?
Does that depend on an understanding
of ownership of the good
as opposed to a rental model?
I mean, I think some of the things
that come up in the rulemaking is --
is a fear that consumers
may have paid for a penny
but want to access a pound.
Does your theory take --
does it matter whether you actually
own the refrigerator or the book
as opposed to lending, or
leasing, or a subscription model?
>> Jonathan Band: You
know, I -- I --
I think there's various
ways to -- to -- to --
to slice the -- the loaf.
And certainly, if when we're
amending 1201(a), I mean,
you could -- I -- I think
the best way to do it is --
is to simply require a
nexus to infringement
so if there's really no possibility
of infringement, it's -- it's --
it's -- it's not within
the scope of the law.
And -- and it's like when
you're drafting a statute,
you can either draft it --
make it really broad and then start
having all kinds of carve-outs
and you know you're never going to
have enough carve-outs, but it's,
you know, it's sort of like
who shows up at the table,
who has enough lobbying strength to
get a carve-out, and that's the --
unfortunately the approach
taken in 1201.
The alternative is you have a
narrower bill, more tailored bill,
and you understand that
there might be some leakage.
And then, if there's leakage,
then you maybe make amendments
to take care of --
of -- of those leaks,
and I think that that's a
better way to approach it.
But, you know, if -- if, you know,
we're not talking about, you know --
you know, there's other
ways of doing it.
I mean, you could certainly
simply, you know, yeah, you could --
you could carve out software or --
or software -- embedded software.
I mean, there's all kinds
of different ways that --
ways that 1201 could be amended.
Again, I think a nexus to
infringement would be the best way
and the simplest way, but there are
certainly other ways that are --
that -- that would
be less effective,
but it would be better
than the status quo.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
And so, could I just, to --
to follow up, so would a nexus
to infringement encompass this,
you know, the -- the
sort of paradigm scenario
that Mr. Adler mentioned
where someone is --
is accessing a copyrighted
movie to watch it?
Would -- would that -- would
-- would that be a nexus?
>> Allan Adler: Yeah, the
problem with requiring a nexus --
>> Kevin Amer: Oh, microphone.
>> Allan Adler: Oh, I'm sorry.
The problem with requiring a
nexus to infringement for 1201(a),
where you're dealing with the
issue of access, is that it fails
to recognize that access to a work
has its own independent economic
value, whether or not
someone is going to infringe
as a result of that access.
For example, you know, we
hear all the time in --
in the book industry that the
difference between the use
of printed books and -- and
digital -- books in digital formats,
whether they're in ebooks that
you -- you have, you know,
that you're looking at in a
device, or whether you're --
you're actually reading
a book online,
is the fact that reading
a book is not something
that actually exploits one
of the exclusive rights
of a copyright owner.
That's true.
But the purpose of putting
a book on the marketplace,
the purpose of actually creating
a work of original expression
in book form, is ultimately
to have people read it,
and that's where the
economic value is.
So the notion that the only way
rights holders can protect access
to their works, or control
access to their works online,
is if they are able
to show that the means
by which they do it is directly
related to addressing the issue
of infringement, neglects the
whole notion of what the real value
of these works is in the
way they're used in ways
that don't involve
infringement at all.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Did you want to respond
to that quickly or --
>> Jonathan Band: Oh well, yeah.
I don't -- I don't want to
monopolize, but I mean, I -- I --
I -- you know, a lot of
it could be taken care
of conceivably in the drafting.
But even if we're not -- it --
it would seem to me that if I --
if I, let's say, rent a -- a book,
right, and I -- I -- I'm allowed --
entitled to it based on my
rental fee to have it for a week,
and I fiddle with the software so
that I can keep it another week,
you know, that seems to me
that might get into this area
of the kinds of, you know,
what we're -- what -- what --
what we may be talking
about, that it --
it conceivably could be
still subject to 1201(a),
especially to the extent that my --
you know, in order to
continue reading it,
I need to continue making copies
of it, RAM copies and so forth,
that are of more than a -- you know,
of more than a transitory period.
So you know, I think even in that
case, it would conceivably --
depending on how you draft it,
it would still be within the --
you know, the scope of
what I'm thinking of.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: So -- so
Allan is absolutely right.
The absence of a nexus
to infringement
in the statute is quite deliberate.
In fact, proposals
like the ones you find
in the Unlocking Technology
Act are not new.
Those were proposals that were made
at the time the DMCA was considered
and they were rejected for a variety
of reasons, including that really
to have done that would have made
Section 1201 rather duplicative
of Section 106, and that was not
the objective of the Statute.
What Congress saw at the time
that they did this was a world
in which you had the type of
scenario that Allan just described
where the value to the -- where
the benefit to the consumer
and the value to the copyright owner
is derived from access to the work,
not necessarily from the exercise
of the Section 106 rights.
So the ability to access a work,
whether it be a book or a song
or a movie or, you know, any
other form of expressive work,
doesn't require you to copy
it, doesn't require you
to distribute it, doesn't require
you to publicly perform it,
but that the value is derived from
your ability to access at the time.
The thing that was talked about
was the celestial jukebox.
We've sort of gone to that model
across the board for different types
of expressive works, and
Congress had that in mind.
That's what -- what -- what
the intended result would be.
And the fact that we are
quickly and continually moving
in that direction is --
is sort of a testament
to the way that it was structured.
I think that's it.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjawani: Thank you.
We believe that a nexus
to copyright infringement
within 1201 cures a number of
the issues that have manifested
over the last 5 to 10 years,
such as the issues of access
to consumer devices that have
software embedded within them
and a variety of other competitive
issues that have been implicated.
But taking this back for a moment
to the discussion we've just had
on the right of access and where
it exists in the copyright law,
Section 1201 -- it sounds like
what we're hearing here is
that Congress intended
to create an --
a exclusive right of
access for authors.
And I don't think we should
be afraid of considering this
in terms of, well, if we have a
nexus of infringement in 1201,
then what happens to
the right of access.
And I think that we should have a
debate on the right of access rather
than on a prohibition
on circumvention.
If Congress wanted to create a right
of access, they could have put it
in Section 106 with the rest of the
exclusive rights granted to authors
of copyright-protected works.
Now, again, looking at some of the
legislative history and the text
of the statute, there's
no discussion of, well,
we wanted to create
this right of access,
it's we want to create incentives to
enter digital markets and we think
that this is a necessary step
to incentivize entry
into digital markets.
And I don't think that,
you know, a explicit right
of access was contemplated
at that point.
In fact, the WIPO Treaty
says, you know,
we want to have adequate
protections for technical measures
that are employed by
authors in the protection
of their rights granted
under, you know, this --
this Treaty which we would then
read in the case of the U.S. Statute
under this Title, which is 106,
which is reproduction, distribution,
public performance and so forth.
In particular, I would say,
you know, the examples that --
that Mr. Band and Mr. Adler
were just discussing, you know,
I think you perhaps
underestimate the creativity
of plaintiff's counsel and their
ability to identify a violation
of 106 in any of these
given particular instances
where you're afraid that
copyright infringement does not get
at the behavior.
There may be an access to a copy.
Well, where did the copy come from?
You know, is the copy lawfully
possessed at the time of the access,
you know, in the case of a rental?
Was it sold?
Well, it was rented.
After the rent -- rental expires,
do you still lawfully
possess that copy?
So I think there are a number
of ways of solving this issue
that don't require such a broad
prohibition on circumvention
that burdens all other
non-infringing uses.
>> Regan Smith: Can you speak
to Mr. Adler's distinction
between access control prohibition
of 1201(a) versus copy controls
in 1201(b), the anti-trafficking
prohibitions?
I mean, that seems
like, statutorily,
they've made that difference and
we could rely on that as opposed
to creativity of plaintiff's
counsel.
>> Raza Panjawani:
It's been our position
that the anti-trafficking provisions
distinction between copy protection
and access protection,
as far as implementation,
are largely indistinguishable;
that a TPM used
for access control is a TPM
used for copy control often.
And we've approached that
in the exemption process
as addressing them more
or less as the same.
>> Regan Smith: Because
you're seeing the merged use
of controls in the industry?
>> Raza Panjawani: Right.
In practice, while the
Statute recognizes them
as two separate types of control,
in practice, we see them implemented
as more or less as the same.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Pierre-Louis?
>> Stan Pierre-Louis: I -- I just
wanted to add that in our industry,
that's not the case because
you have console manufacturers
and you have publishers
who produce discs.
They have to interoperate, but they
do have separate types of access
and copy controls within them.
So in our industry,
we've seen the benefit
of having both of those available.
It's -- it's important to
recognize that we're not trying
to identify infringers, we're trying
to identify and cultivate consumers,
and so, all of these
things help us do that.
And so, access to the work
becomes an important way
of distinguishing the
different uses users want.
Some want it on mobile, some want
it online, some want it on a disc
in a counsel -- in a console.
And I think all of these rules allow
us to play within that framework
and meet customers where they are.
This is not academic for
us, this is business.
And so, you know, making
a nexus to infringement
in many ways harms the
consumers because, right now,
and I think this is the -- the
correct interpretation of the law,
possession of the work is -- is
not what's infringing, it's --
it's the various uses some
may make, and now we're --
we're trying to implicate
more on consumers there.
I think it's important to recognize
that that access control allows them
to make uses and that's what
we're trying to cultivate.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Slover?
>> George Slover: Yes.
I wanted to go back to your
earlier question about ownership
versus other models
of rental or so forth.
I think ownership is
the core focus --
the rights of a consumer who owns
a product, to be able to use it.
And I think you should be careful,
you know, ownership can be written
around by lawyers so that what the
consumer thinks is ownership really
isn't ownership.
So I think it needs to be broader
than just a legal definition
of ownership.
But it's the concept of the
consumer's rights and dominion
over the product that they -- that
they've paid for, that they have.
And -- and I think it -- a useful
starting point is to try to,
if possible, clear the
smoke around the --
the technology and sort of
the complexities of software
and everything, and try to think
of the -- I -- the -- when --
when the DMCA was passed, there
was sort of a recognition,
we need a new legal construct
to bring the traditional copyright
protections into the digital age.
Well, I think on the other side, we
need a recognition that the tried
and true incidence of ownership
should still have value of and --
and presence in the digital economy.
So, for example, taking the
auto software situation,
if it was something that a consumer
used to be able to do in his garage
with a screwdriver, that
was not a copyright issue,
it was not an infringement issue, it
was not a -- an inappropriate use.
If the same thing in the -- the
new world requires getting access
to the software in order to
be able to make an adjustment,
the fact that there's a
technological protection measure
on top of it should not change the
ultimate calculus and objective.
>> Regan Smith: So the Copyright
Office is separately undergoing a
study on software in -- in
embedded devices, and I'm wondering
if what you're saying -- or if
there could be some consensus
around treating software in these
embedded devices differently
than TPMs protecting expressive
works, if that might be another way
to slice it, rather than
a nexus to infringement?
>> George Slover: Well, I'm not a
copyright lawyer and our experience
at Consumers Union -- our --
our point of entry into all
of this was really the
mobile phone unlocking effort
that we helped lead.
So I can't speak too
definitively to the broader issue.
I do see sort of a -- a big
picture conceptual distinction
between the core creative works
and access to books and movies
and songs, on the one hand,
and products that you now can't
use unless you have software that's
functioning inside them.
So what's brought us in, the --
thee concern that we saw was that,
you know, Internet software-enabled
devices, both in the Internet
of Things and then the things that
just sort of operate internally.
But I wouldn't want to
put my finger on the scale
of some of these other issues.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: Yeah.
I just wanted to make two points.
One is, if I understood
Mr. Panjwani correctly,
he suggested that an alternative
approach by Congress would have been
to include access within
the exclusive rights enjoyed
by a copyright owner under 106.
And I would only have
to assume that --
that the constituency
that he represents and --
and that, for example, Jonathan
represents in their criticism
of 1201, would oppose
vigorously such a notion,
because that would
lend the idea that --
that access itself had the
attributes of a property right,
which is what exclusive rights
under 106 really are about,
rather than this being a question of
whether or not somebody who is going
to use their works in a marketplace
manner, making them available
to people but expecting to be
able to assert certain terms
for condition of availability
and use would be able to control
that in the first instance by
controlling access to the work.
And then, the second point I
was going to make is is that,
just to be clear, I -- I --
I was kind of concerned about
seeing the emphasis in the notice
on talking about 1201 outside
of core copyright concerns.
I'm not sure I have any real
grasp of what that phrase,
core copyright concerns,
actually entails,
but it would be a tremendous mistake
to equate that with the notion
of a nexus to infringement,
because obviously,
copyright concerns drive far
more than simply the notion
of whether one of these specific
exclusive rights is violated.
We've talked, you know, always talk
about the incentives to create works
of original expression in the
first place, which is driven
to a large part by the
private incentives involved
with the benefits of copyright.
And I think the discussion
we had a little bit earlier
about access relating itself
to the value of using a work
without infringing it or without
in any way implicating the exclusive
rights of the rights holder,
that is a core copyright
concern, and we shouldn't treat
that notion very narrowly
so that we only think
that core copyright concerns arise
when we're discussing
about infringement.
>> Kevin Amer: And I
think that goes really
to the point Mr. Slover was
making, and I'd be interested
in people's thoughts about it.
I mean, I think what this debate
seems to be sort of struggling
with is, is there a way that 1201
could be reformed that would --
that would include things
like accessing, you know,
circumventing a TPM to
watch a movie for free.
So, you know, so that
would be included.
But things like garage door openers
and printer cartridges
would be excluded.
One proposal short of a nexus
requirement that was raised
in the comments is this idea that I
think Regan's question asked about,
which would be a permanent
exemption for --
for software essential to
the operation of a device.
Is that something that would --
would strike the --
the proper balance?
I'd be interested in
your thoughts about that.
Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thanks.
And -- and yesterday, at the
embedded devices study panel,
we had a swear jar
whenever we mentioned 1201.
So I don't -- I don't know
if the same applies today,
but that discussion was
quite robust yesterday.
And I -- and I -- so, I'll only
briefly reiterate what I said
yesterday, which is that the
same kind of dynamism in terms
of product offerings and things like
that still applies to what is sort
of loosely called the embedded
software market as well.
I mean, and so one of the
examples that -- that --
that I used yesterday was TiVo,
where the hardware was given
away practically as a loss leader
and it was the embedded software
and the services associated with it
which is where the company TiVo
actually obtained its value.
So I mean, there's some complexity
about just having a
broad brush approach
to software that's
embedded in devices.
It would have to be a much more
complicated wording in order to get
at the distinctions that people want
to make so that you are excluding,
you know, printer cartridges
but you're including the ability
to have flexible hardware
subsidy models, et cetera,
that are pretty prevalent
in this market.
So I -- I don't -- I-- we
certainly couldn't support anything
that was just sort
of a broad exclusion
of embedded software
into -- into 1201.
I think that would be a mistake.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjawani: A permanent
exemption directed towards software
embedded in consumer devices
I think would be a good start.
It would address a number of the
overhang issues that we've come
across in recent years such as cell
phones, jail-breaking, tractors,
automobiles, 3D printers,
and so forth.
However, I think it overlooks
the fact that there are a number
of issues that involve,
quote, unquote,
traditional media and
expressive works.
Leaving aside the fact, you
know, that one could argue
that software code is an expressive
work and necessarily must be
so to be protected by copyright.
In particular, there have been a
number of exemptions, you know,
and I guess we're going to
go into this more with the --
with the process panel -- involving
where is the appropriate balance
between access for
fair use purposes,
whether as a documentary filmmaker
or narrative filmmaker
or an educator.
And 1201 places a substantial
burden on those uses as well,
not just those of embedded devices.
And I would also caution
that any attempt
to create a permanent exemption
on software-enabled devices
would instead turn into a fight
over what exactly is a
software-enabled device,
and I'm sure we have
enough creative lawyers here
that we could probably
spend years hashing
out what the appropriate
definition of that would be.
The end result of the litigation
would be not whether a copyright
interest has been violated
but is the thing at dispute
in this particular
litigation a device
within the meaning of the statute.
And that opens up a whole
can of worms, I think.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Pierre-Louis?
>> Stan Pierre-Louis:
I think we have
to tread very carefully
anytime we're talking
about these blanket exemptions.
You know, when we're
talking about 1201,
we're talking about software used
to protect software
of an expressive work.
In our case, we're talking about
software used to protect software
of software, right, because
we are a software industry
that does creative
and expressive works.
And so, when you're talking
about this blanket rule,
you swallow the entire industry.
On top of that, when we look at how
our games are still being played
on various platforms, but in
particular, game consoles,
when you talk about consumer
devices, game consoles are used
for games, they're used for
television, they're used for movies,
they're used for all
manner of distribution now
because consumers demand it and
our companies meet that demand.
So we have to tread very carefully
as we think about what that means
because it implicates more than
just thinking about a tractor.
We're talking about the very
devices that consumers are using
to consume the content
that we're making.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So switching hats
from the Library Copyright Alliance
to the Owners Rights
Initiative I was representing
in yesterday's roundtable,
you know, I -- I --
I think they would support
an exemption along the lines
of what you're talking about.
I mean it, you know,
conceivably a nexus
or something along a broader
limitation would be better,
but this would be a next best --
something that really does target,
you know, the situation where you --
where you do have this
embedded software.
I think the -- and conceivably,
you know, there could be exceptions
to that exception for -- for
Mr. Pierre-Louis' clients.
I mean, that's -- and
-- and -- and -- I --
I welcome Raza's suggestion that we
could spend years negotiating that.
I -- hopefully, I would
have a client in that --
that -- those negotiations.
So that -- that actually, you know
-- my -- my retirement, you know --
that would, you know, be a nice
trajectory towards retirement.
But -- but I think, again,
sort of, you know, just the --
the bigger point is is I -- I
certainly don't think that Congress,
when it was talking about
1201 -- and -- and -- and I --
I was part of those
discussions, as some of the others
around the table were as well --
they really were not
thinking about tractors.
And the fact that we're
talking about tractors
and that that's been an automobiles
and that that's where it's gone to,
does suggest that there
is a serious problem here.
And -- and the fact that we're, you
know, that the Internet of Things,
we're talking about a
world where, you know,
all these devices are going to
be connected and they're going
to be connected by software,
and then the -- there --
there's going to be
these implications
for competition everywhere
because of this Statute.
And so, we need to say, okay, what
do we - - unless you want to --
I mean, you're talking about
how we went from two --
two exemptions to 22 exemptions,
well, I think next year, we're --
you know, in -- in the next
cycle, it's going to be --
you know, it's going to continue to
grow at a -- at a geometric rate,
and you know, it won't take very
long before the whole, you know,
building will be working on 1201.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think Mr. Lowe was next.
>> Aaron Lowe: So some of my
points have already been taken,
but I want to emphasize from
-- from our point of view,
the parts on a car that used
to be reparable using mechanical
means now are require -- are --
you require access to the software.
So we equate now the software to
the parts and once you take away
that right to repair those vehicles,
that becomes a really
difficult issue for -- for --
for the -- for our industry.
You know, people who modify
their cars in, you know,
in their garage should still
have the ability to do that.
And I think your suggestion is
a good one to start out as far
as giving that, you know, some --
some usability, rather because
these are not expressive works,
these are mechanical functions that
are now been taken over by software.
Including, you know,
windshield wipers now that used
to be all mechanical, now
software might control how
that windshield wiper is operating.
If it's a patent, that's
fine, but you know,
the non-copyrightable
function should not be allowed
to be protected.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Dow?
>> Troy Dow: Just very quickly,
I think some have talked
about this exemption
that you suggested
in terms of embedded software.
I think that your question
actually, if -- if I heard it right,
was about software necessary
to make a device run.
And I just -- to me, I'm not
quite sure how to interpret that
and I think it just sort of
highlights how difficult some
of the drafting would be
around something like this.
What -- what comes to mind and
the concern that comes to mind
for me is thinking about,
even some of the early cases,
maybe the very first case under the
DMCA was brought by RealNetworks
and what was at issue there
was an authentication sequence
that in order for you to
be able to use your device
to stream a RealNetworks,
you know, a --
a file that was protected
using RealNetworks' DRM,
you had to authenticate the device
to ensure that you were talking
to a real server that would protect
against copying of the content.
And somebody had gone in and spoofed
the authentication sequence in order
to get around that process.
And so, in order -- they -- they --
that was really software
that was required to make
that device work the
way it was supposed to.
I think in the entertainment field,
a lot of what goes on has to do
with authentication, right.
If you want to use a DVD
player, that drive has
to authenticate itself to
ensure that it's playing
by the rules before
you access the content.
And so, I -- I just want to
urge some caution about how some
of these things that we talk
about in one context really impact
in a totally different context
that would be problematic.
>> Regan Smith: That's a good point,
and I wonder if anyone else could
speak to whether some of these TPMs
or software are running
on, you know, both devices
or protecting expressive content
as well as devices that are not.
In the past rulemaking, we talked
about jail-breaking
and variety of things.
And, you know, and one of the
testimonies there said, you know,
the software is the same no
matter what the thing is.
So whether 1201 should treat that
all as protecting expressive content
or whether you can
make a distinction
if the software is running
on multiple types of devices.
>> Stan Pierre-Louis: I think
I understand the question,
so I will try.
So in our industry, there's
the software authentication
that happens with the game console.
There's also -- there are also
servers where you're playing online,
you could be streaming the content,
you could download the content.
All of those require different types
of software in order to interoperate
because we're soon even going to
have multi-device-type, you know,
where you can go from one
-- multiplatform -- playing.
All those require a lot of
interoperability in software, and,
I think, as Mr. Dow was
saying, it -- it takes --
it takes a lot of thinking about how
those work before we get into rules.
I don't know, for example,
whether some of the software
that operates the machinery
that some others are talking
about here has this other
copyrightable function in it.
But, you know, I don't know
enough about that technology to --
to say, well, that
shouldn't count, right?
I mean, I think that's the --
that's where we have
to be careful to tread.
We know in our industries we're
protecting the expressive works
and so we can speak
very definitively.
But in some of these other
areas, they are also doing things
that are probably copyrightable
and whether you want
to say it's a high
level or a low level,
it's not for me to judge that.
What is important is to understand
that there are rationales behind
each of our uses of software,
and we've got to be
careful in thinking
about what we're implicating
and what we're tripping
over because there would
be unintended consequences.
And notwithstanding Mr. Band's
idea that we just go really narrow
and we just fix the "leaks," for
us, the "leaks" are the business.
You know, once they're
out, they're out.
And so, it's important for us to
be able to monetize that but also
to make sure that consumers
are getting it
in the ways that they want it.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thank you.
And again, I -- I guess to
understand your question, I --
there's certainly software
itself is -- is --
I don't know if that
constitutes an expressive work.
But that -- I mean, that's --
that's where we are interested in
making use of these protections,
and there are a lot of
different licensing models
for the software itself.
And so, sort of protecting
that dynamism I think is also
really important, that it allows
for different kinds of models
for making software available
to different communities, et
cetera, and that kind of --
so there's some price
discrimination benefits, et cetera,
to having dynamic business models.
And I think that that's part of what
has made my industry thrive so much.
I -- I guess I'd rather
approach this from the other end.
If we're trying to -- since we have
the 1201 exemption process in place,
maybe a -- a better reform is trying
to streamline renewals, for example,
that once you've identified
something
that is a clearly acceptable use,
you know, make it a lot easier
to continue that use
somehow, but go --
continue what seems to be a working
process through the Copyright Office
to determine what are
legitimate uses and -- and just --
and streamline the process of their
continuation, rather than trying
to go through and predict
legislatively what --
into the future, that we don't
even really know what that'll be.
I mean, like I -- right
now, cameras --
very often the firmware
in the camera is what determines
the functionality of the camera.
So different levels of cameras that
you buy have different firmware
in them and that's actually what
determines their functionality
because it creates
manufacturing efficiencies, right.
So the firmware ends up becoming
really critical to the operation
of the camera, but it also is
a distinguishing characteristic
from -- of the camera, as well.
And I think that that -- we
want to allow that flexibility
and the efficiencies
that it creates.
So let's look at this from the
other end and streamline renewals
of exemptions, for example,
instead of trying to come
up with a legislative fix that I
think would be a morass and only,
you know, enrich Jonathan
Band's law firm, right?
I mean, I -- to me that doesn't
feel like enough of an incentive
to disrupt the system that
seems to be largely working.
I mean, we're looking at exception
cases and most of the litigation
around these exception
cases has come out in a way
that I think we all
agree was the right way.
And -- and so, that seems
to be a system that's
working, not one that's broken.
And I -- I think that's --
we need to keep that in mind.
I mean, I -- I -- as
a copyright owner,
I don't mind the default case
being -- the default answer --
I said this yesterday --
I don't mind the default
answer being no, right?
I -- there's this notion that,
wow, people are disincented
to start new businesses that
might infringe copyright
because their lawyers can't
assure them that it would be okay
that this creative use of getting
around copyright law would be okay.
And I think it's okay, instead,
that the default answer is no,
which it is in most cases.
It's not that confusing
what's legal and what isn't.
And I think that we need to
look at the exceptions hard
and then find a way to preserve
them into the future as a --
as a better approach, I think,
than rejiggering the law.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I saw one or two cards
go up in -- in response.
So I'm -- I'm sure people
have some responses.
Ms. Greene?
>> Robyn Greene: Thank you.
I just wanted to respond a bit
to this idea first about the idea
that 1201 is meant to limit access
and that that is rightly the case,
and the idea that it's proper that
the default answer should be no
with regard to exceptions.
We spent a lot of time talking
about the marketplace implications
of the effectiveness or
ineffectiveness of TPM measures.
We have not spent a
lot of time talking
about the public safety
implications of DMCA 1201,
specifically with regard
to the chilling effect
that it has on security research.
It was recently noted that there
has been a significant increase
and will continue to be a
geometric increase in the amount
of connected devices in
the Internet of Things.
And what we see is a tremendous
obstacle that security researchers,
in particular, need to overcome
to ensure that, whether it's cars
or airplanes or refrigerators
or TV sets or any
of the other connected
devices that we all use
and depend on, are in fact secure.
And so, when we set access
as the threshold and say
to security researchers
that you can't breach access
because that is an infringement
on the purpose of 1201,
as opposed to protecting the
core intellectual property,
as opposed to protecting
against copyright infringement,
I think what we say to the public is
that market interests are more
important than the public safety
or the potential public
health interests of ensuring
that our increasingly connected
world is in fact secure.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think Mr. Adler was next.
>> Allan Adler: Well, I think
with respect to those concerns,
it's pretty clear that they have
been addressed to some extent
by Congress through original
statutory exemptions with respect
to security research,
reverse engineering,
and also every three years, we
revisit many of those issues
in the context of the -- the
triennial rulemaking proceeding.
But again, it goes back
to the question of whether
or not ultimately the issue of
infringement becomes the tail
that wags the dog of 1201.
1201 was a recognition that
wholly apart from the issue
of infringement, there was value
with respect to access to a work
that had to be within the ability
of the rights holder to control.
Otherwise, the rights holder
would have little reason to expose
that work in an online context
for people to be able to access
and use it without
providing any value
to the rights holder in return.
And -- and one thing
that must be kept in mind
as we discuss these issues is
that courts have not had any
difficulty whatsoever being able
to dismiss the notion that fair
use contains a right of access
to a copy of a copyrighted work.
It doesn't.
It never has.
The arguments in favor of why it
should have never gained any real
traction, and one can
understand why, because, again,
it would subject the notion of
access as an independent venue of --
of economic value to be
limited only with respect to how
that access related to the use.
And if the use was non-infringing,
whether fair use or not,
but if it was non-infringing,
you'd be throwing
out the ability to control access.
And that's really what
1201 was originally about
and continues to be about today.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
So we have about 10 minutes left.
So I think we're going to go around
the table one more time to respond
to this question, it's be -- to
account for the cards that are up.
And then I think we have time for
maybe one more question after that.
I believe Mr. Panjwani was next.
>> Raza Panjawani:
I wanted to respond
to a couple of the prior comments.
Regarding Mr. Zuck's comment
that the default answer being no is
acceptable, I think the discussion
that we're having right now
about the essential software
or embedded software exemption,
I think, highlights the danger
of setting defaults at
no, that the growth of all
of these other issues
shows that, you know,
we thought the default can be no
because perhaps this is not going
to be such an incredible implication
on a vast range of
economic activity.
But it turns out it is.
And, I think, it's worth
reevaluating whether the default
being set at no makes sense in
-- in -- in light of all of this.
I would also say that
the examples of successes
that have supposedly
occurred are, for example,
I'm assuming the Chamberlain
case and the Lexmark cases,
but for each one of those cases,
there's a case, for example,
like I believe 1201 came up with MDY
v. Blizzard and I believe it came
up in particular in the RealDVD
case, where a court was faced
with software that allegedly could
be used for supposed fair uses.
And the court said, well,
I can't get to whether
or not the use that's
being enabled is a fair use
because there's a circumvention
happening here.
So we never get to
establishing case law
on core copyright because of 1201.
I will also point out that
I think that in response
to Mr. Adler's comments that access
is a right in and of itself, that,
you know, the comments regarding
the passage of the DMCA is
that we're creating this ancillary
right of access for the purposes
of discouraging and disincentivizing
and preventing infringement
of the 106 rights, not access
for the sake of access itself.
The fear was that digital goods are
so easily reproducible, so trivially
and so easily distributable
in an online format
that you need this additional
protection to back up 106,
not as a right that
stands in and of itself.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Slover?
>> George Slover: Well,
Raza just covered my point.
>> Kevin Amer: Okay.
Thank you.
Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Yes, thanks.
I just wanted to respond briefly
to the public safety comment made
earlier, that the -- I -- I --
I think that it's just as
equally important to recognize
that there's public
safety implications
to tinkering with embedded software.
And so, again, if we bring public
safety into the discussion,
security isn't the
only component of that.
It's also how the software is being
used and how the interconnection
between the software is being used
increasingly in medical devices
and other areas where there's a --
an enormous public safety issue
associated with allowing people
to tinker with embedded software.
So I mean, I -- we can have that
conversation, but it's going
to be much broader and
much more complicated
than I think people would
hope that it would be.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: Well, I -- I would
just again point out, I mean, we --
we -- we talked about this at
the very beginning, that for --
for the models, for example,
in the industry I represent
that are most important,
things like library elending
or subscription on-demand or
print on-demand or being able
to rent a work on-demand, the issue
there is about software being used
to provide access to the expressive
work that's protected by copyright.
And we shouldn't let the
difficulties created by the fact
that software has a dual
identity as both a copyrightable
and protected work in itself and the
fact that its functionality is used
for purposes of controlling
access to a separate
and distinct expressive work,
to place those expressive works
in a position that
Congress had not intended.
I, again, respectfully disagree with
the comments that were made before
about the right of access being
something that was considered only
with respect to the issue of
trying to reduce online piracy.
It was not.
It was specifically the case
that Congress sought to be able
to create online markets
for copyrighted works.
And that was the reason why access
had to be subject to some degree
of control that was separate and
distinct from what you intended
to do with the work once
you acquired access to it.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So I'll -- I'll
respond to Allan's previous comment,
not this last comment, but -- but
the -- the -- the issue, at --
at least, the -- where I see the --
the big problem with 1201(a)
in this access point, is again,
this is access to something,
whether you have --
it's one thing to get
access to something
to which you don't have
a legal right to access.
I mean, you don't have a
-- you don' t -- you're --
you don't lawfully possess that
item, as opposed to something
that you've paid for and that
you have lawful access to
and your ability to get inside that.
And -- and this really, you
know, and -- and -- and --
and this really gets to the point
about security testing
and -- and so forth.
So yes, Congress did
recognize that, and --
and, you know, and came up with a
few permanent exceptions, and --
and so there was one
for security testing,
one for encryption research, one
for interoperability, and so forth.
But there wasn't one,
let's say, for, you know,
the testing of the Volkswagen
for purposes of determining
that they were committing this
enormous fraud on, you know,
consumers around the world.
And -- and, you know, but -- and
the idea there is that a person,
you know, presumably, you
know, whether it was, you know,
consumer report or whoever who would
hopefully be able to do that kind
of research would buy
the Volkswagen, right?
They're not going to
steal the Volkswagen,
they're going to buy the Volkswagen,
and then they should be able
to do the testing of all
sorts about how the, you know,
how the software in it works.
But a lot of that is not
covered by specific --
by existing exceptions in the DMCA.
And -- and moreover, there is this
whole generation of, you know --
yes, there are hackers and there
are people who do various kinds
of testing sort of in the
gray areas of the DMCA,
but a lot of people just
have decided not to --
that it's not worth it,
it's not worth the risk.
And -- and in the last -- yesterday
we were hearing about how, you know,
there there's this whole -- you have
a lot of academic researchers --
I mean, you have some who are
willing to get into this area of --
of-- of -- of encryption
research and -- and all the --
all the other kinds of hacking
technologies to figure out how --
you know, how, let's say,
Volkswagen gained the system
and to detect those
kinds of problems.
But if you're -- if you're
working at an academic institution
and you know that there
are going to be --
there are colorable legal
issues, or there's a potential
of a legal issue, and you
have to worry about funding,
people just don't go into
that area of research.
It's just not worth it.
It's hard enough to get published
and tenure to have to worry
about the -- the -- the
legal issues on top of it.
So I think, you know, there --
there's, again, as more software
is included in more things,
there's all kinds of
problems in that software,
whether it's consumer
protection issues and --
and safety issues that are
not covered by exceptions,
and to rely on the
exemption process to hope
that every three years maybe
an exemption will be granted
to cover whatever you
want to do, is --
is simply not sufficient to take
care of the enormous problems
that we could fix probably
by relatively simple changes
to the DMCA, narrowing
its scope a little bit.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think Ms. Greene was next.
>> Robyn Greene: So I was
really going to say a lot
of what Mr. Band just said with
regard to the fact that the current,
permanent, and exemptions are
not sufficient to encourage
or allow the types of security
research that is needed.
And there is a chorus of
security researchers who will --
who will and have said the same.
I would also just say that
because of the obstacles posed
by the rulemaking process and the
fact that you have to go through it
because the default is no,
that serves as a further chill.
The last note that I would want to
make on -- on this point is that,
when I was speaking to the
public safety concerns on --
and the public health concerns,
that not being able to have
as robust security research
as we might otherwise have,
I was not suggesting that that's
an equity, that it is appropriate
for the Copyright Office to weigh.
In fact, it is our position that the
inquiry should be limited to whether
or not the proposed use is --
would constitute an infringement.
And so, we do align
ourselves certainly more
with public knowledge's
position on that point.
I was merely making the point
that by expanding the
inquiry beyond whether
or not a proposed exemption would
constitute an infringement does
in fact implicate significant
public policy concerns negatively.
And then, the last thing
that I would note is, the --
the idea of access
being this threshold
and this important protection, when
we keep hearing this from industry,
it is sort of like the
industry trying to have its cake
and eat it too, because oftentimes,
while there are certain industries
that are able to protect
their products, as --
as the gentleman from ESA previously
stated, there are other industries
that simply can't and
that still want to rely
on limitations to access under 1201.
And a good example of
this is a study conducted
by Columbia University which found
that at some point 46 percent
of Americans engaged
in some form of piracy.
So clearly, piracy is still
a significant problem,
as many industries themselves say.
Yet the study also found
that the vast majority
of those individuals wound
up purchasing more digital
products online legally than those
who never engaged in piracy at all.
And so, I do think that there are
some really interesting findings
there that it would be worth
thinking about in terms
of the value of limiting access.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
So we are just about at the time
and I see a couple of other cards,
and I just wanted to
ask one more question.
So in your responses,
you might want to --
I invite you to address this
in your responses as well,
and that's the question of how
prevalent, in your experience
as practitioners, is it for 1201 to
be used for what you might regard
as anticompetitive
purposes or to enforce 1201
against consumer products?
On the one hand, you know, we've
heard -- we've heard that, while,
you know, you have the
Chamberlain and the Lexmark cases,
those are several years
old, and in any event,
the courts rejected the
plaintiffs' claims in those cases.
On the other hand, we've
heard that, in any event,
there still is a chilling
effect by the --
by the prospect of
litigation in these areas.
So it would be helpful
for us just to --
to have your perspective sort of
on how commonplace these sorts
of claims are in the 1201 context.
And I think Mr. Dow was next.
>> Troy Dow: So I -- I guess --
>> Kevin Amer: And we -- and we
-- and forgive me, I -- we'll --
we urge you -- everyone to be brief
because we're right
up against the clock.
Thanks.
>> Troy Dow: So in -- in response
to your question there, it --
my own firsthand experience is
that there's not -- I -- I don't --
I don't have firsthand experience
with a lot of that type of activity.
What I see in that area
is largely anecdotal.
I see it raised in the context
of the rulemaking proceeding.
I also see a rulemaking
proceeding where, as you said,
I think there were 27 exemptions
asked for and 22 granted
in the last round, and so I'm -- I'm
not sure that process isn't working.
I mean, it was intended to be
something that could be flexible
and respond to these things.
And, in my experience, I'm
not sure it -- that it isn't.
I had my tent up really to respond
to Mr. Panjwani's notion that --
that access was not
intended to be separate
from the rights of
the copyright owner.
I mean, that -- that notion
just simply isn't correct.
It was very clearly discussed, very
clearly contemplated at the time,
and I just wanted to highlight,
just coming out of the House
Judiciary Committee Report
where they -- they say the
technological measures,
such as encryption,
scrambling, electronic envelopes
that this bill protects can be
deployed not only to prevent piracy
and other economically
harmful and unauthorized uses
of copyrighted materials,
but also to support new ways
of disseminating copyrighted
materials to users
and to safeguard the
availability of legitimate uses
of those materials by individuals.
It absolutely was not limited to
protecting access for the purposes
of preventing infringement.
It was protecting access
for the purposes
of incentivizing these new business
models, many of which don't rely
on exercises of the rights
of the copyright owners.
In our business, those are
the new business models
that we're engaged in.
We've got a whole suite of apps
that allow you to gain access
to our linear television content,
whether it's Disney Channel
or whether it's ESPN or whether it's
ABC, to allow you on your iPhone
to watch those things on
the go that is controlled --
the access to those things is
controlled through authentication
to ensure that you have
permission to have that access.
But it's not contingent
upon the exercise
of the rights of the
copyright owner.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
And quickly please, Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjawani: Just
responding to your question
about the prevalence of --
of 1201 claims against
sort of consumer activities
and pro-consumer activities, I would
note that that's in part asking
for us to prove a counterfactual
in that it's our perspective
that the existence of --
if we assume that many
people are law-abiding
and the law prevents engaging
in pro-consumer activity
that would be prevented by 1201,
then that activity
just isn't out there.
I think we have seen the examples
that did come out are involving,
you know, the inkjet printers.
And I would point out that we
filed to clarify that legal ruling
to make sure it extended
to 3D printers.
And that attracted a voluminous
filing by Stratasys, a major player
in the industry, opposing that
on the ground that no, no, no,
we have this right to lock you
into our first party filament.
And most recently,
another competitor
of Stratasys 3D systems just
announced end-of-life of one
of their printer lines,
which had, you know,
lock in a first-party filament.
And I think that underscores the
importance of exemptions like this
and sort of the effect
that 1201 has.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Pierre-Louis?
>> Stan Pierre-Louis:
I promise to be brief.
First, I think it bears repeating
that 1201's been a success story
in what it aimed to do, right --
in the twin goals of both
getting more broadband out there,
getting more devices innovated, and
getting works online and on devices.
So it's been a success, and
so, we've got to really think
about how we tinker with it, right?
There are two types of
tinkerings here, right.
And we've got to be very
careful in how we approach that.
The other is that we've seen
innovation really blossom.
It hasn't been chilled.
And what businesses
like is certainty,
both in what they can and can't do.
And when they know that they
can make that investment
and get a return, they
will invest more.
And they've done that.
And I think -- I think that's
been proven out, and so,
we've got to be careful how we think
about the exemption process
and all of those things.
But I think first and foremost,
we've got to look at this
as a success story that
we want to continue.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Weissenberg?
>> Brian Weissenberg: Well, I'm
not a practitioner just yet,
I'll be graduating in a month
and passing the bar, but I --
I would again put your
attention to the --
the TracFone reply comment
from last year's triennial.
They list -- they do a great job
of listing all the success
they've had using the DMCA
to protect their anticompetitive
lock-in model.
Again, we emphasize
that's not appropriate --
that's not an appropriate
use of 1201
and we urge the Copyright
Office to make a statement,
a clear statement saying that
that no longer has a place
in this process, so.
Thank you.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
And, I think we'll
wrap up with Mr. Band.
>> Jonathan Band: So I
know Donald Trump thinks
that unpredictability is a virtue.
But when counseling clients,
unpredictability is -- is not good.
I mean, not my unpredictability,
but the unpredictability of the law.
So after the DMCA passed, looking
at a plain reading of 1201(a),
it was pretty clear
on its plain reading
that it could be used
anti-competitively.
And I had to counsel
clients, yeah, you can't --
you know, if you try to circumvent
for this purpose or that purpose,
to keep competing in the
aftermarket, you're --
you might have a problem.
And then, along comes the --
the Chamberlain v. Skylink case,
and I said, okay, well, you
know, silly me, you know,
I was just reading the plain
language of the Statute and,
obviously, it means something
different from the plain language.
But that's good, I like
Chamberlain better, and so,
now you can compete
in the aftermarket.
And then, along comes MDY and
says, you know, and they said, no,
you know, Congress meant, you
know, the plain -- plain --
plain language controls
and this interpretation
of Chamberlain is wrong.
And so now I have to tell
my clients, oh, well you --
you could have -- you used to be
able to compete in the aftermarket,
now you can't compete
anymore in the aftermarket.
And so, that's where we are now.
That sort of depends where you are.
I guess in the Sixth Circuit, you
can compete in the aftermarket,
in the Ninth Circuit, you can't
compete in the aftermarket.
And -- and just to, you know, as --
as Raza, said, you -- and -- and --
and -- and the gentleman here said,
you know, you just have to look
at who is opposing exemptions
to see how it is being
used anti- competitively.
So we see in the 3D context,
the 3D printer context,
it's being used anti- competitively,
in -- in the TracFone case,
and then, of course, you
know, when -- when --
when all the major automobile
manufacturers are opposing it
because it's -- they --
it's clearly, they're --
they're opposing the
competition that would be enabled.
So it's quite obvious
that it has a potential
for enormous anticompetitive
implications.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I -- I think we have
to leave it there.
I -- I apologize.
Thank you to all our panelists.
We're a little bit over time, so if
I could ask that we limit the break
to 10 minutes, if -- if panelists
on session two could plan to be back
by 10:50, that would be great.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.